Now, in this section of Sequencer's Features and Tools, we're going to explore the Animation
Mode toolset that is available when animating with Control Rig in Unreal Engine.
The first thing you will encounter when working in Animation Mode is the addition of two animation-specific
tabs, the Anim Outliner and the Anim Details panel.
And just like the name suggests, these are animation-specific versions of the already
familiar Outliner and Details panels.
The Anim Outliner is designed to show the controls as organized by hierarchy in your
active Control Rig.
Here, you can show or hide the Control Rig controls or quickly select a specific control
from the Outliner to make it an active selection in Sequencer.
The other tab is the Anim Details panel, which provides animators an isolated view of the
Euler Transform channels for the selected Control Rig control that they are manipulating.
The next set of Animation Mode tools are a series of animation buttons found in the
Animation tab when Animation Mode is active.
The first of those buttons is the Select button, and in general, I would just keep this button
enabled while animating a Control Rig.
When active, the Select button only allows users to select the Control Rig controls preventing
any accidental selections of things like the Scale Mesh, Actor, Geometry, random Static
Mesh props or set pieces, particle systems, lights, or cameras.
The next tool is the Poses button, which activates the Control Rig Pose window.
The Control Rig Pose window allows users to create and then share pose libraries for commonly
used character poses.
So for example, any kind of character-specific poses that must be frequently replicated across
multiple sequences, scenes, or shots can be created and stored in a shareable library.
Poses that add specific personality or quirks to a character's body mechanics can also be
shared and then applied to something like performance capture data to alter or exaggerate
that performance to fit the character's personality, allowing other members of the animation team
to take on some of the work, reducing the burden on the character animation leads.
The next set of tools we will talk about is the Snapper and Pivot buttons.
The Snapper button is used to define a parent and child relationship between a Control Rig
and an Influence Actor for creating keyframe animations on the Control Rig controls through
a temporary control attachment.
This can be very useful when implemented in specific scenarios where you want to have
an animated asset influence the position of the controls to generate synchronized keyframe
animations on the temporarily attached Control Rig control.
Just like the example shown here, where the parent, which is the bouncing static mesh
ball, is used to create keyframes on the child Control Rig IK Hand control.
Of course, additional polish animation will be needed to make this animation look better,
but it does provide animators a solid synchronized starting point, saving some animation time.
The next button in our toolset is the Pivot button, and just like the name suggests here,
the Pivot button does exactly what it says it will do, allowing an animator to adjust
the pivot point, creating an offset for the Control Rig controls.
Finally, there are just two remaining animation tools that need to be discussed, the Trails
button and the Tweens button.
The Trails button serves two functions.
The first is going to help you with visualization of the animation path in the viewport.
Motion trails can be visualized and information related to that path can be added or subtracted
depending on the user needs.
The second function is direct manipulation of the motion trail inside the viewport.
Motion trails can be moved or modified, allowing an animator to perfect those arcs and look
for any bumps or unnatural motions that might not be obvious.
One thing to note, the Trails button can make curve manipulation easy, but they are
very processor intensive, so be careful.
Users will need something pretty powerful hardware wise to make the curve manipulation
run smoothly.
Lastly, we have the Tweens button, which is used to adjust the interpolation between keyframes
using three preset tween modes.
The tween modes are the BN mode, which blends keys to the nearest neighbor.
The PP mode, which push and pulls curves between the selected keyframes.
And the TW mode, which tweens the selected keyframes.
Alright, that's it for Sequencers features and tools.
In our next section, we will jump right into some hands-on animating and engine, beginning
with laying the groundwork by building our first animation assembly.